foreign
[Music]
today I'm going to be talking about some
of the ways that parsing out the
functions and packages in your files can
be helpful for organizing and viewing
viewing projects and I'll also be
introducing a new package I wrote called
Fun spotter that provides some helpers
for parsing analyzing and organizing
functions in different project
structures
okay so I hope I'm not the only one here
who maybe follows some of their favorite
our developers like a little too closely
so for example like before going to
sleep rather than going through
Instagram I'll just like scroll through
the recent GitHub activity of my
favorite R Developers and then when a
like new blog post or new book comes out
that I'm super excited about it's like a
major event for me and I just want to
jump straight in and um I would love to
say that I'm just this sponge of
information and immediately I'm just you
know know exactly what I'm doing but
usually it ends up kind of looking a
little bit more like this
uh and you know there's all those things
coming at you and you're trying to
figure out you know how these things
relate to each other uh and I've come up
with this kind of heuristic where I'll
just start uh kind of like writing down
the functions that I see as I'm going
through the new book or blog or whatever
it is
um and I'm happy that I've seen other
people in the art community that kind of
share the same
pattern as I do here's a post or a tweet
from Alex cookson where he says any
other our stats people find b-rob's tidy
Tuesday screencasts useful I'm at a
Sprint spreadsheet with timestamps for
hundreds of specific tasks he does and
then another example from uh Jeff
Rothschild who made something similar
for different developers in the Tidy
model space particularly Julie silgi and
other authors there and I think that
creating a reference table like this for
yourself can be really helpful in terms
of kind of building a you know mental
model for what's going on and printing
these different functions that you can
go back to and check on and give
yourself a little bit of context of the
materials that you're working through uh
one downside with doing this is it just
takes a long time and you also may miss
some specific examples or packages as
you're going through and creating these
by hand and I think that this is where
something like fun spotter can be useful
either in supplementing these materials
or in creating an initial reference
table for yourself so I'm going to start
by just showing what a typical Fun Spot
or workflow looks like and what the
output looks like I'm going to give you
a few seconds to kind of soak this in
and this is also another opportunity if
you find you can't read the code to
scoot closer up there's plenty of seats
in the front so I'll just give you a few
seconds to see if you can soak this in
okay so what I'm doing here is I'm
specifying uh the GitHub repo where
Julie silke's blog lives and then I'm
just pulling out all of the individual
functions and packages that are used
there and then we have links to the
relative paths within the repo as well
as the URLs where these files actually
exist and then I think past is something
like this into a nice little HTML lookup
table can give you a nice little
reference table for reviewing whatever
material you're in the process of going
through so here I'm just looking up
where are the cases where she's used
written about random force in the past
and this gives this nice little way of
looking this up another place where this
is useful is just in those cases where
you kind of want to sift through some
set of information you may not even
remember the function or package that
you saw her write about you just
remember okay there was something that
was useful that I think she did and you
just kind of want to look through a
reference sheet and I think that's also
where these types of tables can be
really helpful and provide nice little
supplements to whatever other method you
use for searching information or helping
you kind of in your learning process
so next I want to talk a little bit
about each of the different kind of
groups of functions that exist within
fun spotter so one set are these list
files functions that essentially take in
some location and return all the
different files in that location then
there's a set of functions that spot
things so in this case we're talking
about spotting functions and then I have
a variety of helpers that either
manipulate the output of these objects
or are helpful for plotting and then
there's also a bunch of unexported
functions that I'm not really going to
get into today but can help with certain
situations that you may run into if you
have like different dependency
structures than just kind of like the
standard setup
okay so now I'm going to walk through
this step by step just so you can see
the details of how how this works so
after running list files GitHub repo
what were is returned are the file paths
for each of your R and our markdown
files within that repo and then also the
URLs to those
next we pipe this into spot funds files
which is going to for each of those
individual file paths parse out the
actual functions and packages within
them so if we just hone in on an
individual element within that spotted
column you'll see this is where our
actual function packages that are used
within that file exist and then that
next step the unnest result is just
going to take each of these individual
data frames containing the function
packages and put them into a more simple
data frame structure that you can use as
a reference table for yourself
and where most of the work that's going
on here is really in this uh this like
spotting step and one thing about r that
adds a little bit of complexity here is
that when you do a library call you're
attaching all the functions within that
package
um so what fun spotter does is
essentially try and recreate what it
thinks that search space is going to
look like it takes a variety of steps to
do this so that when it identifies a
function it can say I think this this is
the package this function is actually
coming from
I'll note too that this takes a few
seconds to do for each file so while you
can do it for um you know a few for
hundreds of files if you try and do it
for Millions this isn't the going to
work it's going to take too long if you
have any like ideas and suggestions for
how to do this faster definitely feel
free to open a GitHub issue for me if
you happen to be an expert in the space
um and I'll also note that if the if you
don't have the package installed locally
Fun Spot is not going to know which uh
package that particular function came
from it's just going to say unknown so
you if you and if you don't want to
actually install all of those packages
that you may have for some you know uh
set of files that you're running from if
you don't want to install those across
all your projects you may want to start
off by using something like RN so that
you can keep you know the packages
you're installing for this specific to
that project
and again this process of recreating the
search space is currently set up to be
used on like self-contained files and by
that I just mean picture like an R file
or an R Market file that has a bunch of
Library calls at the top so it's going
to work on things like repos for blogs
uh or books and things more along those
lines it's not going to work so well on
things like targets workflows or you
know shiny apps or other types of
projects that have more sophisticated
dependency structures potentially that's
just the currently it's set up more for
these
and again the goal here with this
example is to create some kind of
reference table that you can use for
yourself
but outside of just creating reference
tables for you know blogs or books or
screencasts I think another set of
examples are just your own code I know
for me my own code Snippets can get
really disorganized and tough to keep
track of here is a tweet from Chelsea
where she says I have so many Snippets
of our stats code and Untitled files
that have useful bits of code that I
want to catalog somewhere but I don't
know where would be best and I
definitely had this experience
particularly with my GitHub gists if you
don't know what GitHub gists are they're
just like a place online where you can
save a little code Snippets and for me I
know I'll like make some little example
of something and post it on GitHub gist
and then kind of forget about it and
then sometime down the road I'll think
okay I know I did something along the
space and I can't quite remember what
that was and this is where I think
creating a little reference table for
yourself so you can go back through and
glance through those or search through
you know the what you what functions and
packages you were using in your product
examples can be really useful and this
is I'm using this example just for your
own code but you could picture else in
an organizational context it may be
useful to you know get a sense do this
across a wide range of different folder
structures you can see okay what
function packages are different people
using
and just one little caveat about these
examples they're a little bit manicured
sometimes depending on what the
dependency structure looks like or what
the files that you're actually saving
like there may be a little bit of
cleanup that I'm kind of just not
exposing you to here because I don't
want to scare you away too much
okay so up to this point I've gone
through a few examples where we are just
creating you know reference tables for
yourself but this can also be used for
actually directly organizing your files
and I'll walk through an example using
blog down so I started blogging
uh yeah in 2020 after uh the RCA
conference in San Francisco Rebecca
barter had a really great talk that
inspired me to start blogging more
regularly and um one issue I ran into
when creating my uh blogs initially was
my tags really didn't work coherent at
all I'd have you know ml machine
learning I'd have data science spelled
three different ways I have a bunch of
synonyms for each other for my tags so
to the point that the tags were really
not any useful way for actually
organizing my posts and I thought a
better way of organizing my post would
be to just directly see which packages
are being used in each post and use
those as the way to actually organize
those tags so that's where this function
uh spot tags can be really helpful where
what this does is when it actually
renders the file it first goes through
checks checks which packages are
actually being used and then puts those
into a format that it can be used for
the little tags at the top of the header
for your post so now rather than
actually having to put any thought into
what my tax would be for my blog I just
had the spot tags it does all that for
for me I don't need to type anything out
and it can just kind of like it's one
less thing to worry about when you know
blogging can already be someone
intimidating thing to do in the first
place and then if you actually go and
look at like what the tag section of my
website looks like all my posts are
organized based off of whatever packages
are used within them which I think gives
this nice clean coherent way of actually
you know setting things up
okay so now I've talked through some
examples of creating reference tables I
just went through an example of how you
can use this to organize your files
directly and the third area that I just
want to touch on really briefly is I
think they can also be helpful to
actually analyze this information so
this there's a lot of potential data
here this is again Julius silky's blog
maybe we want to see how do these
different posts and packages relate to
one another so here's another example
where I'm passing these into this
network plot in this case I'm actually
just parsing out the packages not the
functions so in the network plot we have
each circle here represents an
individual package each Square
represents an individual file the
connections represent those cases where
a package is loaded within that
particular script and you may notice
that there's you know some clustering of
your groups here and we see okay there's
these two big clusters one of these are
packages Associated primarily with the
core titiverse and then another set of
packages that are associated primarily
with tidy models so you know just
glancing this you get a sense that Julie
obviously writes a lot about tidy verse
and tidy about tidy models and does a
lot of Tidy verse code in terms of doing
her cleanup you can imagine another
author who writes more about spatial
analytics may have some different set of
packages Central to what their posts are
largely about and this is just kind of
one example I think there's a lot of
different ways you could take this you
can imagine trying to explore the
relatedness between different projects
or between what different authors are
writing about or you could also use this
to help organize those files directly
based off of like what types of things
actually exist within them so this is
just kind of like a little taster
example but I think there's a lot of
interesting things you could do here and
I just want to reference a few other
interesting projects this is not within
the art community directly but if you're
just interested in kind of like
visualizing code space or using
visualizing code repos or using the
information that's within the files to
help organize those files these are just
a couple other projects I think are
worth you know looking into if you're
interested
okay so I hope that you will take the
jump in and try out the package
um I'm planning submitting it to grant
for the next few weeks so if you try it
I'd love to get feedback from you
um and I also have on my readme just
like a few examples of reference tables
created using fun spotter if you use
this and create some reference table
definitely open up an issue or a pull
request and I'd be happy to add that
there just to get some other examples so
thank you
thank you
[Music]